huh
y'all are lucky
that uh
i'm not in the mood
to test another
outlet right now
because it is too hot
to be clothed
this
this
this [ __ ]
that's uh
that's where i'm at
despite what you may think based off my
current mood
uh which is primarily exhaustion
uh this is
actually in fact
water no joke
it is just water
because it's too hot to be drinking
anything else
not only do i know the song too damn hot
rebecca i performed it in
uh kiss me kate i got to sing that song
and i i have a burlesque number that i
do to that song so yes i am
very
familiar with cole porter's too darn hot
ah
i'd like to coo
with my baby tonight
all right can't keep going
i don't know at what point the uh
nonsense will
catch my singing
uh
i saw the suicide squad really glad
capaldi got to deliver an
anti-government speech he should get to
do that for the rest of his career
agreed
more than ice water no
it's really not not today
uh i thought you'd be getting drunk
tonight i'm don't have the energy to get
drunk
i i i have a baseline
like i have to have a certain amount of
motivation
and
willing and like have to be at a certain
amount of energy that i'm willing to
crash from
to bother drinking i have neither
of uh
of those things at the moment
no i have not
uh seen the new
owl house episodes yet
my kid has but she doesn't want me to
watch them
without her despite the fact that she
has watched and rewatched them already
so until um
her mother and i have the handover
um i i won't see them so that probably
means later this week
thoughts on strzezinski and doctor who i
have no thoughts until it's official
as per usual
did henry hit your area much henry
didn't come close
we barely got a sprinkle
i've got one complaint that the mic
sounds weird anybody else
or is it uh
is it just the one person
how am i doing mentally
exhausted i'm actually probably more
mentally exhausted than physic like i'm
mentally exhausted and i'm physically
just overheated
so that's
that's the uh that's the combination
yeah mike is weird echoey ah crap okay
great
um
give me a minute
all right so that's doing what it's
supposed to do
um
technical
bull crap
uh
weird
there isn't a secondary is there
no that's off
anything else no
no
uh
that's the only input
well crap
well i mean
can i be underst uh you know hang on a
second let me try something
that
that that
all right hang on
[Music]
all right um
hang on
and
how about there how about that is that
better for people
how do we sound now do we still sound
like crap do we sound better do we sound
worse can you hear me
is there anybody out there
uh
that's a that's oh that's an album to
avoid right now
random comic fact deadpool married the
fiance of dracula had a kid with her let
that sink in
freaking deadpool cuckold dracula sorry
for the bad language
cuck is i mean like the way people use
it is bad but like
cuckolding it's uh
it's a thing that happens some people
dig it
did buffy the vampire slayer slayer ever
have a bad season in your opinion
um yeah it had two season four and
season seven that is not to say there is
no good in either one there is good in
both of them but neither taken as a
whole is very good
i'm watching the daleks master plan
which is bleak as hell while playing
spec hops the line i'm very unhappy see
that sounds like self-abuse to me if i'm
going to be honest
based on what you've seen bellows or
hordak well see alyssa i feel like
that's a spoiler you just dropped at me
because
you wouldn't even compare the two unless
bellows in some way becomes more
humanized
um or is given more justification for
the ways being which is something i
wasn't aware of
so
i
neither have an answer and also i'm a
little annoyed
ah
do you know vera means faith apparently
no i didn't because it means truth
so
i think it also depends on the language
i think the the name or a similar name
has different meanings in different
languages
last week for the first time since march
2020 i went to a movie theater to see
rifftrax live hobgoblins with a couple
friends
we have a blast have you been to a
theater no i have not been to a theater
i've been to a drive-in that's as close
as i've come
what's the temperature there ah
see a lot allow me to
offer uh the standard new england cliche
before i tell you this number uh it's
not the heat
it's the humidity
uh it's 81 degrees
with a 57 humidity which is better than
it was earlier but it's not good it
makes the air feel like pea soup
thoughts on spider-man no way home
trailer i mean
my
uh immediate reaction is up in the break
room of geeks so you can see that there
i mean beyond what i already said there
um
oh like
anybody who's making the claim that
doctor strange is actually mephisto in
disguise so that this is
um like their way of doing the
um
one more day
plot plotline uh screw you and shut up
first of all they can evoke it without
having to actually do the plot line
which is actually what the marvel things
have been in general
um
and secondly it's never mephisto
mephisto at this point is to the mcu
what the ronnie is to doctor who it's
never mephisto it's never the ronnie
uh
it's 89 in maryland right now high was
93. tomorrow's gonna be damn near 100.
uh
oh
evasuration
thank you so much so this i should have
mentioned earlier um super chats
guarantee that i will read your comment
and or question
and it gets you a heart to show my
appreciation because i stole that from
jessie gender i have no shame about that
whatsoever
greetings and
salutations who would make a good uncle
bed from the mcu my pick would be joe
patchy if only for reuniting him with
marissa tomei
you see peter
thing you gotta understand is great with
great power
comes great responsibility
it'd be amazing
i can't actually do a joe pesci
i get like if i'm doing quotes of things
he's actually said i can kind of do them
a little bit but
not really um
but
so
anyways an actual answer to that
question i don't know like i'm i'm
bad
at fan casting questions
uh
it's just they they
my brain
doesn't work
that way i'm like i'm trying to think
uh marissa tillman's age range
her actual age range
um
you know not the standard oh you know
you can get a guy 20 years older and
call them a couple like hollywood likes
to do
um
hmm
these these two utes yeah that
i mean if you're gonna do joe pesci um
my cousin vinnie is always a google one
to go to i'm done with this guy i'm done
with this guy
ah let's see
oh
didn't uh realize oh sorry uh seti
davido
thank you very much you get a heart i
appreciate it for the super chat didn't
realize you were from new england it's
even wicked cooler that you are yeah
like the thing is i don't really have a
new england accent or not a distinct one
at any rate like my mother's from boston
um
so like she really loved uh
the movie the departed because uh after
she came out of the movie she loved how
they talk normal
um
and i'm not even exaggerating that is a
direct quote
so
but like i
i grew up in vermont i don't have a
vermont accent vermont x is kind of a
softer main
um in a lot of ways
i did pick up the yup
like that's that's the go-to we don't
say we don't say yes we don't say yeah
we go yup
yup
so uh that's kind of all i've got other
than that i have a relatively neutral
accent so i i don't know if people clock
that i'm
new england all that often
if doctor who gets a new composer do you
have any fan pics
however wild for me it's jessica curry i
don't know jessica curry's work
um
i don't know
what the hell was the name of the guy
who did oh hang on it's like the only
thing that's coming to my head i like i
hope you realize how fried my brain is
how crap i'm gonna be
um
at these questions
john powell that's what i was trying to
think of
there we go
i know words
have you seen shang chi yet if yes no
spoilers uh but is it good and not too
marvelly if that makes sense i have not
seen it i don't know when i'll get to
see it i don't know when i have time to
see it i don't know how i would see it
i don't i'm definitely not going to a
theater anytime soon
um
like i want to watch it but it's
i don't know
did he is did he get the premier
access nonsense on disney plus
i mean that's the other thing like
pretty much all the um
review content at this point is
um
is going up on
um
on the break room
because the the reviews just do
don't do that well most of the time
that's going to include what if going
forward by the way
there is a video coming out tomorrow but
it's uh it's not a whatever well there
will be a what-if review but that'll be
in the break room
um
doubt you've
doubted but have you watched the boys i
have not i've stated repeatedly that
i've heard very good things about it i
suspect i might even enjoy it
um
when i get around to it but
like
i'm in no rush i don't particularly like
um garth ennis's writing who did the
original comic
would you ever do a burlesque number to
let me be good to you from the great
mouse detective no but the only reason
is there is a uh
there's another performer in the state
who already does that one
we try not to step on each other's toes
in terms of
um
duplicating
[Music]
uh each other's numbers like you can
occasionally use the same song as
another performer
so long as your um
your concept for the number is
significantly different
i have had other people ask me like oh i
was thinking of a song to the number to
the song but i know you do one like is
that okay and mike will tell me the idea
the devil is like yeah that's totally
different from what i did with it go
nuts
um but you know it's a professional
courtesy currently saying shang
sang
shang chi
had a premiere for professional
reviewers and such it drops in theaters
september 3rd comes out on disney plus
45 days later
i don't know
i don't know like you need to i i don't
get uh
i don't get
screeners
like
disney does not send me
early review
stuff
so
um
if it's not if it's not out to the
general public it's not even worth
asking me if i've seen it
ah
did you watch andromeda nope never saw
that one
i i am aware of it and i know sorbo's in
it so i definitely wouldn't really want
to watch it now
but uh
no i never saw that one
asking questions in this
chat is like karaoke you sit for a while
waiting for it and you can't go anywhere
in case you miss it let's face it
everyone's normally drunk yeah that
tracks
that makes sense
do you think jms could take over doctor
who possibly
maybe i don't know
i don't know
i i'm i'm i know i did the one video
because i'd gotten like a bit of
information that i was able to vet to my
satisfaction but like i'm not a
speculative person
so asking me you know
this person taking over or that person
in this part or what actor do you think
should play this like i don't know
i don't know
ah
here i tell you three times you missed a
super chat asking about your book i did
it's not it's not on the list of
super chats that i've got um
so
uh whoever asked that
um at me in the chat and ask again
uh
so i'm sorry to whoever that is and i'm
sorry to caroline um but it like i've
got the list of super chats that are
logged
and it is uh it's not on there so i'm
not sure what was up with that
um the super chat that i do have in here
uh is captain omni
gets a heart thoughts on the rumor of
shazam being renamed captain shazam
following the new mini-series i prefer
it over just shazam if he can't be
captain marvel i
honestly i prefer just shazam
i feel like the captain title is
uh
is kind of weird
um
for someone who isn't in the military
like for how marvel actually does
captain marvel makes sense to me there
but otherwise like i don't love it as an
honorific for a hero
um sorry to ask but you're writing a
book i've already written
um
a book i i wrote
i wrote a novel
that came out earlier this year
um
i've got other writing that i'm working
on no promises or plans for releases on
anything else
um
but i've i've written one novel i've
written um a book about being
genderfluid
and i have written him self-published to
play so
um
that's that's my writing currently
available for purchase
oh
i see a whole lot of questions from
people just just
trying to get my goat up and i i i
don't have the strength not ghana
uh renee garza for a fiver wants to know
if your book is available and where
huh i don't know why that
didn't show up okay renee
uh apologies
so have a heart um so yes the book
dreams of fire is currently available
um
through
amazon
um in
digital paperback illustrated or on
illustrated or hardcover full color
illustrated you can also um because i
set it up with a
distributor you can also get it through
your local bookstore or library they can
acquire it
so
um yeah again it's called dreams of fire
it was published with nathaniel wayne
listed as the author so
generally you're gonna want to search
the both of those together because if
you search
just one or the other you might get
other stuff
excuse me
but there we go sorry i missed that
earlier i i'm staring at the list of
super chats it's not there it's really
weird
oh great so i write tube i'm
experiencing some kind of writer's block
how do you deal with that
i
see i have the opposite it's not that i
have writer's block it's that i am too
buried in other [ __ ]
to um
to have time to write lately
which is annoying
uh
have you seen hell of a boss by
visi pop i've no idea what that is
may look like a kid show it's not for
kids i neither know what that is or who
that's by or where that is or what or
the what the who or the i'm almost 40.
so like you you you
threw a bunch of things at me that like
don't make sense
it's funny that i'm thinking of becoming
a youtuber writer's channel pup
announces he might be ready to leave
i mean were you planning on aping his
style
you're going to be the new pup
um
like i i know i know um cause like i i
talk offline with the with channel pup
uh now and then so i know he's he's like
the fun is kind of going out of it for
him and honestly if if you've hit that
point
i um
i think it's it's best to do what what's
going to be best for you
and if it's not fun and it isn't your
living
there isn't you know the idea of
continuing to force yourself to do it
is um
you know is
something that you just you keep doing
it it's it's it's gonna get worse it's
gonna feel more and more and more like
work and more and more and more like a
chore
uh renee
uh monkeyo
thank you very much
for the super chat check out the trailer
for mitch jenkins and alan
moore's the show it's on youtube
i will have to do that after the stream
i would do a live reaction the problem
is
um if any of the stuff from my if the
audio from my phone gets picked up and
broadcast
then the bots might grab this stream and
demonetize it which would negate your uh
super chat um and i think it would
probably be pretty boring for me to mute
my mic and people to just watch me watch
something um captain omni came in with
another one thank you very much
non-binary here i'm writing a
frankenstein book would it be good rep
if the monster who's the hero identifies
as non-binary
it's gonna come down to
execution um
honestly
as long as you're avoiding
well-established and problematic tropes
there isn't uh an inherently good or
inherently bad
representation by making any given
character
um
non-binary or trans or
what have you um again barring certain
specific like if
if you've got a character who's stalking
women given the current uh discourse
around um
around trans people maybe don't make
that character a trans woman
um you know
so you know
assuming you're avoiding stuff like that
um
making
making frankenstein's monster non-binary
is not inherently good or bad it's gonna
come down to how it's handled within the
work here's what i would say you have to
be careful about in terms of one of the
tropes that
um is a little bit
um
of of a sticking point at least for me
with non-binary representation
specifically
it's that
the
biggest source of
non-binary
representation in media is in fantasy
and in science fiction
with non-human characters
with
aliens
shape-shifters
um robots androids constructed beings
things that aren't just people
there is uh right now a dearth
of representation of just non-binary
people just people
human beings
so
that's the main thing that i would say
to be careful of if you are making
um
frankenstein's monster or some
equivalent thereof uh non-binary now in
some ways if if they are assembled from
a number of various body parts it would
make an awful lot of sense especially if
they are assembled from the body parts
of
um multiple genders or anything of that
nature so like it's it's not an
automatic um i'm saying just like be
careful to
not just lean on the idea
of um they're non-binary because of
their inhumaneness
just be careful about that
uh
so hold on
there was something
i missed
okay so molly is suggesting slay the
spire for the twitch channel a video
game card game that might be a cool
replacement for hearthstone
huh
well i might look into that like i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be opening things up
a little bit more
when
two things uh happen one
when i finish paranormal uh which i've
probably got a couple of weeks left on
given that i'm only playing once a week
right now
and
the other one being
uh i
my new computer coming in which is
ordered
i'm waiting for the damn thing to be
built and sent to me and that won't
happen until next god damn month
but um
once those two things happen
uh it will open up the possibility of
what i could play instead
uh now as far as the the one you
mentioned
like at this point
i don't i don't need a hearthstone
equivalent on my computer if it has a
phone app version
um i might look into that because that
was sort of where i'm feeling the loss
of hearthstone a bit more it was
something for me to to fiddle with on my
phone uh that didn't require too much of
my direct attention and it's it's sort
of replacing that as that's what i'm
working on
have any ghost stories i
have
i have sort of written a ghost story
once so
trying to think of the short version of
this
a couple years ago uh some friends of
mine
wanted to like
pool resources and try and you know and
knowing what locations they had access
to and what kind of performers props etc
that they would have access to
um
wanted to
make a ghost movie like you know
shoestring budget all that stuff
um i ended up writing the script for
that it was their concept it was their
idea but i ended up writing the the
script so like if it had ever been made
which it wasn't it would have been like
story by you know the other people
involved script by and then it would
have been my name so
like i have written a ghost story once
but i haven't um fully conceived of one
from start to finish
uh
before do you think that deckard for bl
from blade runner is a replicant i think
it doesn't matter
that's what i think
uh well it only took a year and an
unnerving amount of water but i finally
fixed one of my characters and made him
better without actually having to change
all that much congratulations lewis
yeah
it could be tough trying to get these um
these things sorted when you're when
you're writing and revising especially
speaking of which there was another
super chat
from uh captain omni
without giving anything away uh the
monster is more similar to hellboy cross
with indiana jones identifies as a
monster
not as man or woman okay
so
in that case what i would say is if you
want to have them identify as monster
that's fine but don't have anybody use
the term non-binary because then you are
literally linking the idea of of
monstrosity to a non-binary identity so
don't do that
um
so if if
like if they identify as a monster that
is
fine just be careful with how
they talk about themselves and how
people talk about them
um
and honestly even be careful of pronouns
my
i don't know if this would work but my
natural inclination would to
would be to have the monster use it as a
preferred pronoun because even just
having um
the
having it be they them still links it
somewhat to non-binary identities and
then if they identify as monster then
we're back into
um we're back into issues again whereas
if you
had the creature actually choose like
voluntarily and prefer
it
pronouns which to be clear there are
some people who do but generally it's a
not a thing to do um
but if you if you had the monster
actually do that i think it would give
you a chance to
explore an existence outside of being
either male or female without feeling
like you are directly invoking
um
human non-binary identities and and
tying them to monstrosity because that's
that's the trap you're gonna have to
watch out for
question do you know any media that can
juggle comedy and seriousness and pull
it off and not get tonal whiplash
um
uh what comes to mind is the yakuza game
series and dragon quest 11. um like
there are things out there that can do
it um
the thing is
it's like
i think a good example is
the the movie four lions which
the comedy is is very broad and very
silly
by the end it's freaking harrowing um
but the reason it works is because it's
not turning here's the thing tonal
whiplash is less about the marrying of
comedic and dramatic elements and more
about the transition from one to the
other
um because the other thing uh
that i could cite would be
shauna the dead which by the end has
become a pretty legitimate
horror movie but it's become that
gradually it's not like there was a
moment where suddenly
jokes stop now it's horror
you you have that transition and if
you're going for an overall tone shift
you gotta do it gradually and slowly
so tonal whiplash is less about the two
tones you're trying to marry and more
about the way that you switch from one
to the other and or try to blend them
together at the same time so like most
things it's about execution
evil dead 2 now evil dead 2 is
interesting because i would actually
argue evil dead 2
deliberately does tonal whiplash to
comic effect
um which is a very hard thing to do um
that's the kind of thing that's
basically like doing what you're not
supposed to do on purpose and having it
work which almost never happens
so evil dead 2 is actually kind of fun
as a weird outlier in that way i think
i think fiddler on the roof does the
tonal shift well going from humorous to
being very human oh that oh actually
that's a that's a really good example
because definitely when that show starts
it's it feels
light and fun and airy and by the time
it's over it's
you're like oh
dude
uh
let's see
i need to check out the evil dead movies
honestly
only the second one is great
third one's pretty good i actually
prefer the theatrical cut to the uh
director's cut
sorry and the original is interesting as
a as a
origin point
or um
or just as like an artifact of
low-budget
cinema that doesn't exist anymore um but
as a movie it's kind of
[Music]
um
you know props to the careers that it
started but other than that it's just
kind of
uh
which of the two would you rather watch
an american werewolf in london or the
exorcist oh probably american werewolf
in london because at least the uh
at least the zombie scenes are
are a good time and i like that one
better than the exorcist anyway because
the exorcist
like american werewolf in london has
parts that are fun and i enjoy the fun
parts and there's a couple of decent
horror stuff i just think it's slightly
overrated
similar to your opinion on into the
woods movie i don't think the wall works
without the interval in the concert
that's interesting because i've never
i've never seen it in concert um like i
listened to the album a lot when i was
in high school and i watched the movie
and the movie is a
um
is a strange beast
it's fascinating i haven't rewatched it
in ages parasite intentionally did tonal
whiplash and did it really well i still
haven't watched that i still need to
i have a lot of things i need to watch
have you seen the wreck movies i have
not i know what they are
um but i have not seen them
what are the best seasons of buffy and
angel in your opinion season two of
buffy season five of angel
a kind of villain i love is a villain
that can terrify me like dark knight
joker
the thing is i tend to lean personally
towards
um and this this is as a as an audience
member not so much as a writer but
uh as an audience member i tend to
gravitate towards fun villains
as opposed to legitimately scary
villains now like there can be
i like a villain that isn't trying to
scare me the whole way through but can
pull it out at the right moment
um
but i tend to i tend to favor fun
villains overall
um and a lot of things that genuinely
unnerve me tend to be
movies taken as a whole
much more so than you know just the
villains in them
uh
what will you do if nicholas hammond
isn't in no way home i don't know who
that is
so
probably nothing
speaking of evil dead i'd love to see
bruce campbell as uncle ben that would
be fun
that would also be amusing
uh
okay so
one more
from captain omni thank you very much uh
the monster is almost akin to superman
does that work thank you for the advice
your channel has really helped me on my
non-binary journey oh
thank you that's wonderful to hear
um
[Music]
so yeah if
that's assuming you're taking
the superman angle of
not human but dwells among us so not
separate
but also not of the same kind that that
could work that that's feasible as a as
a general tone to the to the angle of it
ah let's see
jupiter's merged evil incorporated
perry the platypus
ah i've actually never seen a full
episode of that show but i know
doofenshmirtz because he's all over
memes so
i know him
a platypus
perry the platypus
uh well if you like fun villains pretty
soon hopefully i'll start filming my own
project ooh would you be interested in a
series about villains
uh that have a habit of winning
cocky villains can be very fun
so yeah that that could work
still a great impression oh thank you
i sounded right in my head but that
doesn't mean anything
i heard bruce campbell was supposed to
be the villain spider-man 3 but they
changed the story well it's hard to
track down
what was originally supposed to be in
spider-man 3
um because it kept changing a lot so
trying to sort out what was genuinely
supposed to be there or what was tossed
out as an idea at one point or what got
changed in what cup for us is actually
really hard to parse
fully that production on that thing was
a mess
basically the first act ends when the
final break in the wall
being put in separating the band from
the audience also the movie cut hey you
which is a real crime yeah it did bug me
that hey you is not in the movie
like i remember when i first listened to
the album hey you was my favorite track
so yeah that that was that was an odd
omission
a game series i want more people to get
into is dragon quest because i feel i
was
i feel like here in the west a niche
whereas in japan it's freaking
juggernaut see i i have played
two
dragon quest games
the original
on
on these on the nintendo
which was marketed in
the west is dragon warrior
i played that
never quite beat it
but i did play that and i played
dang it what was it it was on
ps2
so i think it was nine
it was eight or nine
i started it but i lost focus and
drifted off to other things
um
but yeah i mean like the the thing is
it's never gonna be the juggernaut over
here that it is in japan because a big
part of its design and appeal is very
old school and it's old school for a
type of game that has always just been
niche in america so you kind of can't
really get around that
john vinyls
thank you very much for the super chat
and i asked this earlier but how
familiar are you with the source
materials of disney animated classics it
varies from story to story like i'm
pretty familiar with the little mermaid
uh the original i'm pretty familiar with
snow white
i'm
passingly familiar with the original
cinderella
um i don't know original sleeping beauty
very well
i don't know
very much about the jungle book i know a
little bit
um so like it's mixed like i know
rapunzel
beauty and the beast
i i think the ones that like i basically
kind of only know the disney version of
um you know other than just the cultural
osmosis is i never knew the specifics of
aladdin other than like well there's a
genie in three wishes and that's kind of
it
so i didn't really know much about that
one
um
i didn't know the ice
uh queen
which was the starting basis for frozen
frozen became very much its own thing
uh by the time it went up
but
trying to think of some of the other
um
oh things like 101 dalmatians lady and
the [ __ ] those are based off things
never
i don't know any of those
worth a dang at all
uh
anyway
uh sorry folks give me just one quick
second bear with me please
uh
all right sorry about that
uh louis
ward
thank you very much for the super chat
and hi fixed my phone so i'm back i was
randomness welcome back
welcome
if you could play a dragon quest game
nowadays i recommend dragon quest 11
uh
yes that's the title it's so good in
that like
um
it's got like a really
weird almost tongue twisty title ms wiki
wolf stop yelling at me
i mean i i actually mean that
when i see all caps directed at me in
the chat
it really
really
bothers me
i have mods
i have people who will get my attention
if my attention needs to be gotten and
if you feel that i am that you are
failing to get my attention you can go
to heroin you can go to pirates they
will get my attention for you do not all
caps at me anymore
i ignored it up to this point please
stop
it feels like being yelled at and i
don't enjoy it
okay
are we talking about jessie because yes
jesse has been
jesse has been sick she
she gave herself uh gave herself a cold
so
she'll uh she'll be all right
she's been getting better but yeah i uh
i had the podcast record with her
on monday she's she's still a little
under the weather but she is getting
better so she'll be all right is it just
water today yes it is
genuinely just water
do you have thoughts on phantom of the
paradise i know that it's a thing that
exists and that's uh that's kind of all
i've got
um i've never seen it so i have no
further thoughts about it
let's see
uh one great thing about the newer
warmaster box set is they extended the
awesome theme music ooh
that was really good music
have you ever watched once upon a time
have you heard of it i have heard of it
i haven't watched it my partner liz has
told me some of the nonsense that goes
on in it
any niche fairy tales you think fiction
should explore more for me it's the boy
who went forth to learn fear
um
not off the top of my head
um
i probably are but
i'm drawing a blank at the moment
i have not seen owl house episodes six
through 10 yet i mentioned that earlier
um
so i am going to take a look at the
discord real quick
which is a reminder the
council of geeks discord is a patreon
exclusive perk let's see what we got
won't make the live stream but here's a
random question based on recent real
events in the uk
what would you do if tom cruise landed a
helicopter in your back garden
well um
given the size of my back garden i
would probably be asking him to replace
all the trees that would have been
decimated by the helicopter's rotor um
other than that
i honestly do not know
that would be just a very surreal
experience
uh toby mcguire would be a fun uncle ben
he's 10 years younger than marissa to
may but you can't seriously expect me to
believe she's 56.
um well she is
uh
fun idea but like a little too meta and
like definitely not gonna happen like i
honestly i don't think we're ever gonna
see uncle ben in the mcu i think they're
just not gonna
i just think they're not gonna show him
ever and honestly i'm kind of okay with
that
like
we had the definitive uncle ben
um already in the rainy movies
um
so i'm i'm okay
with um
with just
having the lesson
still be there
um without having to see the moment it's
it's kind of like how i don't need to
see
bruce wayne's parents get killed anymore
yeah i got it
i don't really need to see uncle ben
give the life lesson and then die again
yeah i got it
oh let's see all right popping back to
the chat i was oh and i just got sent a
link for the
tom cruise
as was during him shoot for mission
impossible oh good grief
tom what are you doing what are you
doing man
my goodness
uh
i stopped watching once upon a time a
long time ago i don't recommend it it's
one of those things that like went on um
just i remember being like wait that's
still on
that was sort of my recurrent thought on
that kind of the same with walking dead
actually
i'll bounce remember to be good people
chat and very your inspiration keep
doing you never change thank you logan
you be good people too
um
oh
got a
heart to give to sophia christina botha
hey hun uh get my email yes i did i
gotta i gotta pull that back up
sorry i'd like
i've spent
the last few days in a haze of editing
uh video editing and i'm probably gonna
be stuck there
for most of what's left of the week and
just lots of stuff just is not um
is not sinking in as
as fully as i would like
um
yeah so yeah that's right you had
emailed me about
j michael strzenski jms uh taking over
um
doctor who which like if i i will have
more thoughts on it if it happens
um
at this point
like he's just kind of a yeah that would
work it would make sense that's kind of
where i'm at
uh
if toby is actually returning in no way
home
he should still say the line okay yeah
i'm fine with that i'm actually i would
actually be totally okay with tobin
mcguire saying the line that would
actually make a lot of sense in some
ways
have you ever watched luther british
crime drama starring idris elba i did i
watched the first series and i wasn't
grabbed
i don't i actually don't know what it
was it just for some reason it just
didn't
it just didn't hook me
i just watched them like okay
that
that was the thing
it's good to see you back on tick tock
it was wrong what they did to you yeah
tick tock is uh
i'm not uh
not thrilled with that platform right
now i can safely say that
am i buffering for anybody because i'm
getting an alert that i might be
but i don't know if i actually am
discworld better than once upon a time
the watch and i mean like i feel like
you're stacking the deck to compare
discworld to anything
um
hope you haven't heard all bad things
about once upon a time i'm hoping to be
a mad dictator in october whatever works
for you
uh
let's see
should luke smith be
uh the new torchwood with the stars from
sarah jane
adventures um
i have
mixed
feelings about that idea
on the one hand i would like to see them
come back
but
um
and like logistically if you're going to
do that sticking them in torchwood would
make sense but like speaking personally
i'm not sure i want to see those
characters
dirtied up the way they would have to be
to fit the tone of torchwood so
[Music]
fair enough but one thing a lot of
people who watch the show say to me is i
love dallas you agree i found alice
interesting i didn't love her
she was actually a character who i feel
like i'd seen more than a few times just
not as a woman which
works well enough as far as gimmicks go
did you see the suicide squad i did i
got a i have a review up in the break
room of geeks which is the uh subsidiary
channel
last season of once upon a time
absolutely sucked and was so
disappointing
i feel like
whether or not a bad final season
ruins a show
usually
not always
but usually depends on structure of the
show and whether it was something that
felt like it was designed to
build
somewhere or if or if things were more
self-contained
like there's a reason that
you can't go back and watch even the
good seasons of game of thrones anymore
because it was always built it's
building to that
cluster [ __ ] of a finish
so like how can you how can you enjoy
the build up when the ending sucks
uh
halfway through season three of once
upon a time i got so angry i almost
flipped my tv
uh i heard they made a live action
phoenix right it looks amazing that was
a while ago wasn't it wasn't that
takishi mikey
made that
i feel like that that's
old news or are you saying like they're
doing an english version
um because hold on phoenix
uh
phoenix right
ace attorney yeah 2012.
and it was takashi mikey
man that guy's got a weird
a weird filmography holy cow
i recently rewatched the other doctor
who spin off class i don't know if you
watch it yet uh
if not it's simple don't i never got
around to class at this point that's on
the that's on the list of maybe if
someone commissions me
stuff
uh
i feel like shows have better final
seasons when writers have the endings
planned out i would agree but the
asterisks i have to put on that is and
they are allowed to stop when they want
to because it's not uncommon for writers
to have an ending planned out but then
be told uh no we're renewing you for
another three seasons so sort yourself
out
or it can actually go the other way
because then you get gotham because
gotham's last season is not very good
and it tries to do way too much and part
of the problem is
they
um they had a plan for the ending but
they also
didn't abandon their plans for what was
supposed to be a fifth season that
wasn't going to be the ending so they
also crammed in the ending they were
playing they were planning to do
dollhouse did something similar it gets
weird that's one of the problems with
the planned ending is if you don't get
to end at the season you're planning to
then you either have to cram everything
in if you've been canceled early or you
have to stretch everything out if you
are renewed more than you had intended
to be so
it is good to have a plan just don't
just don't be married to it you know
it's not about the destination it's
about the [ __ ] mystery boxes well it
is if you're jj abrams you know it's not
about the desk to something it's about
the whatever
if somebody can tell me where that
quote's from i will be very happy
my other wish for no way home is more of
a stupid one but i'd like to see uh
dang it the comment got away from me
hold on
uh i'd like to see shailene woodley
finally get to play uh the version of mj
to
garfield's peter
i feel like that version of peter
is probably just sat up on a gargoyle
crying for the rest of his life
that's
it was just kind of the mood he gave
you're going to love miss quill from
class she's the only good thing about
that show
oh
i mean i heard there were some decent
things
uh
if someone commissions you to watch
class they want you to suffer
it'd be like me commissioning you to
watch ferris bueller oh
that's ooh that's a harsh thing to evoke
uh that happened to suture
supernatural had a perfect ending but
then kept going uh though there was a
twist that was almost good that i need
to make a video on
do it make the videos do the thing
um yes thank you carowind that is a very
good idea yeah i do i should call it a
night because i have
oh i gotta figure out what i'm gonna do
i have too much to edit i have break
room stuff to edit i have saturday's
video to edit
i also might need to just actually step
away from my computer for a little bit i
don't know
um
but uh i i do have there will be a new
video on this channel tomorrow so as i
said the uh what if review is moving to
the break room
but there is going to be a video
tomorrow
actually about
only fans and the whole mess that's
going on
uh with them right now that's going to
be a premiere it's going to be a little
bit later than i normally do it that's
going to be premiere at three o'clock
eastern
normally i do them at noon um but i
don't want it to uh overrun uh
potentially or bump up against
my twitch streaming which uh that's at
10 30
again eastern time
so
uh yeah
i think that's about it
is there a bar you'd not cross even if
commissioned
probably but i don't know what it is
uh
in any case i hope um
everybody takes care thank you very
thank you very much for just um
[Music]
indulging me
like like i said i'm kind of mentally
exhausted i feel like i'm not in the
best mood right now but
you folks seemed
happy enough to spend time with me and
that
that helps
so
thank you everybody
i hope that you
stay safe
out there
things are getting crazy in some areas
again but
mostly
i want you to remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings so until
next time
this council's adjourned
mccabe